PROMISES THEY MADE TO ADDRESS
THE DEVASTATING EFFECTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE.
TODAY I CAUGHT UP WITH THE
FORMER VICE PRESIDENT AL GORE,
THE FOUNDER AND CHAIR OF THE
CLIMATE REALITY PROJECT ABOUT
JUST HOW MUCH IS AT STAKE RIGHT
NOW.
MR. VICE PRESIDENT, THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR JOINING US.
YOU FAMOUSLY RAISED THE ALARM
ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE WITH YOUR
DOCUMENTARY "AN INCONVENIENT
TRUTH" AND YOU WERE AWARDED THE
NOBEL PRIZE FOR THAT EFFORT.
SINCE THEN, GLOBAL TEMPERATURES
HAVE RISEN ON A STEEP CURVE.
HOW CRITICAL IS IT FOR WORLD
LEADERS TO DELIVER RESULTS AT
THIS COP26 SUMMIT BEFORE IT'S
TOO LATE?
>> FIRST OF ALL, THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME ON, WOLF.
IT'S VERY CRITICAL.
I THINK MOST EVERYBODY
UNDERSTANDS THAT BY THIS TIME.
WE'RE USING THE THIN SHELL OF
ATMOSPHERE SURROUNDING OUR
PLANET AS IF IT'S AN OPEN SEWER
PUTTING ALL OF THIS
HEAT-TRAPPING POLLUTION THERE.
WE'VE SEEN THE CONSEQUENCES THAT
THE SCIENCES PREDICTED WOULD
OCCUR ALL THESE HEAVY DOWNPOURS
AND FLOODS AND DROUGHTS AND
HURRICANES AND SEA LEVEL RISE
AND ALL THE REST.
AND SO THERE IS A WIDESPREAD
CONSENSUS NOW IN THE U.S. AND
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD THAT THESE
LEADERS REALLY HAVE TO COME TO
AGREEMENTS THAT LEAD TO MUCH
MORE SUBSTANTIVE ACTION MORE
QUICKLY.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN SAYS THE
GOALS OF THE PARIS CLIMATE
ACCORD ARE STILL WITHIN REACH.
BUT A U.N. REPORT ISSUED JUST
LAST WEEK ESTIMATES THAT
EMISSIONS WOULD NEED TO BE CUT
SEVEN TIMES FASTER THAN CURRENT
COMMITMENTS TO MEET THAT GOAL.
IS THAT STILL POSSIBLE?
>> YES, THE GOAL OF LIMITING THE
TEMPERATURE INCREASE TO NO MORE
THAN 1.5 DEGREES CELSIUS, THAT'S
2.7 DEGREES FAHRENHEIT, THAT
GOAL IS STILL WITHIN REACH.
COUNTRIES HAVE TO MOVE FASTER,
BUT LET ME SAY THIS.
I THINK PRESIDENT BIDEN HAD AN
EXTREMELY SUCCESSFUL VISIT HERE.
TWO DAYS THAT -- WELL, REALLY
THREE, CRAM PACKED WITH SPEECHES
AND MEETINGS AND ACTIONS THAT
REALLY DID MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
HE GAVE A TERRIFIC SPEECH IN THE
BIG MEETING OF LEADERS.
HE FOLLOWED THAT UP TODAY WITH A
TERRIFIC INITIATIVE ON FORESTS
AND THEN ON METHANE WHICH NEEDS
MORE ATTENTION.
I THINK HE MADE A HUGE
DIFFERENCE WITH HIS TIME HERE.
>> MR. VICE PRESIDENT, HOW DO
YOU REACH THAT GOAL WHEN LEADERS
OF SOME OF THE WORLD'S BIGGET
POLLUTERS -- RUSSIA, CHINA,
SAUDI ARABIA, AREN'T EVEN
ATTENDING THE SUMMIT AND AREN'T
REALLY STEPPING UP WITH
COMMITMENTS?
>> WELL, IT'S REGRETTABLE THAT
PRESIDENT XI JINPING DID NOT
COME TO THIS EVENT.
I WILL AGREE WITH THAT POINT OF
VIEW.
BUT REMEMBER THIS, THAT THIS
MEETING IS MORE THAN JUST WHAT
TAKES PLACE IN THE MEETING
ROOMS.
IN ADVANCE OF THIS MEETING, IN
PREPARATION FOR THIS MEETING,
THE PRESIDENT OF CHINA MADE A
VERY SIGNIFICANT COMMITMENT TO
END ALL OF CHINA'S FINANCING OF
OVERSEAS COAL PLANTS AND THEY
WERE BUILDING 72% OF THEM.
SO THAT'S A MAJOR COMMITMENT.
AND THEN IN ADVANCE OF THIS
SUMMIT, HE ALSO MADE A
COMMITMENT ALMOST A YEAR AGO, TO
REACH NET ZERO, A LITTLE BIT
LONGER TIME FRAME THAN I WOULD
LIKE, BUT STILL THE DIRECTION OF
TRAVEL IS CLEAR, AND HE MADE A
COMMITMENT TO PEAK THEIR
EMISSIONS BEFORE THE END OF THIS
DECADE.
AND WITH A COUNTRY THAT BIG,
THAT'S NOT NOTHING.
SO THEY ARE MOVING.
THEY'RE BUILDING MORE WINDMILLS
AND SOLAR PANELS THAN THE REST
OF THE WORLD PUT TOGETHER.
IT'S A HUGE COUNTRY IN A GROWTH
PHASE.
SO THEY NEED TO DO MORE.
OUR COUNTRY NEEDS TO DO MORE AS
WELL.
EVERY COUNTRY NEEDS TO DO MORE.
>> THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, AS
YOU KNOW, JUST ANNOUNCED THESE
COMPREHENSIVE NEW RULES AIMED AT
CUTTING METHANE EMISSIONS ACROSS
THE OIL AND GAS INDUSTRY.
HOW FAR WILL THIS GO IN
ADDRESSING THE PROBLEM?
>> WELL, THAT'S A VERY
SIGNIFICANT, VERY IMPORTANT
INITIATIVE THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN
ANNOUNCED.
THE CLIMATE SCIENTISTS WILL TELL
YOU THAT METHANE IS ALMOST 60%
OF THE CAUSATION FACTOR THAT IS
REPRESENTED BY CO2.
IT HAS A SHORTER LIFETIME IN THE
ATMOSPHERE BUT IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE EACH MOLECULE
OF METHANE IS 84 TIMES AS
POWERFUL AS A MOLECULE OF CO2.
AGAIN, OVER A SHORTER TIME FRAME
BUT THE BEST WAY WE CAN GET
K
QUICK RESULTS IS BY CUTTING
METHANE, AND WE CAN DO IT
BECAUSE IT HAS ECONOMIC VALUE.
THEY SHOULD CLOSE UP THESE
LEAKS, STOP THE FLARING OF IT
AND REALLY, WE OUGHT TO STOP
BUILDING ANY NEW GAS OR OIL
PIPELINES.
THAT'S WHERE A LOT OF THESE
LEAKS COME FROM.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN IS STILL
PUSHING TO GET HIS OWN CLIMATE
LEGISLATION PASSED THROUGH
CONGRESS.
BUT IT NO LONGER INCLUDES A KEY
PROGRAM THAT WOULD HAVE REWARDED
UTILITIES FROM MOVING TO CLEAN
ENERGY AND PENALIZED THOSE WHO
DIDN'T MAKE THE TRANSITION.
CAN PRESIDENT BIDEN STILL GET
THE U.S. ON TRACK FOR NET ZERO
EMISSIONS BY 2050 WITH THIS
SCALED BACK PLAN?
>> YES, I THINK HE CAN.
AND NOT ONLY THAT, I THINK HE
CAN STILL HAVE A 50% REDUCTION
BY 2030, WHICH MOST PEOPLE THINK
IS THE MORE IMPORTANT GOAL.
IT'S A WAY STATION TOWARD NET
ZERO IN 2050.
WHEN HE COULD NOT GET THAT CLEAN
ELECTRICITY STANDARD, HE
REGROUND.
GINA McCARTHY AND JOHN KERRY ARE
HERE.
I'VE TALKED TO THEM ABOUT IT.
THE NEW PROVISIONS, OF COURSE,
THEY HAVEN'T PASSED IN THE
CONGRESS YET, BUT I STILL HAVE
SOME HOPE THAT THEY WILL PASS.
SENATOR MANCHIN WHO HELD IT UP
HAS SAID HE NEEDS MORE TIME TO
STUDY IT.
I HOPE THAT WE'LL END UP GETTING
MOST OF THAT PACKAGE AND THAT
THE U.S. WILL BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE ON THE PATHWAY TO
MEETING THOSE COMMITMENTS.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN ACTUALLY
APOLOGIZED AT THIS SUMMIT FOR
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
DECISION TO PULL OUT OF THE
PARIS CLIMATE ACCORD.
CAN WORLD LEADERS REALLY COUNT
ON THE UNITED STATES KNOWING
ANOTHER PRESIDENT COULD UNDUE
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S EFFORTS?
>> WELL, YOU HEAR SOME TALK OF
THAT SORT, FOR SURE.
BUT IT'S IMPORTANT TO REALIZE
THAT A MAJORITY OF REPUBLICANS
NOW, ALONG WITH AN EVEN BIGGER
MAJORITY OF DEMOCRATS, ARE IN
FAVOR OF TAKING BOLD ACTIONS TO
SOLVE THE CLIMATE CRISIS.
SO I AM HOPEFUL THAT PUBLIC
OPINION WILL MAKE A DIFFERENCE,
WHICHEVER PARTY IS IN POWER.
OF COURSE, I'M A DEMOCRAT AND I
HOPE DEMOCRATS KEEP THE CONGRESS
NEXT YEAR, BUT I'M EVEN MORE
HOPEFUL THAT THIS SURGE OF
PUBLIC SUPPORT FOR ACTIONS TO
SOLVE THE CLIMATE CRISIS WILL
HAVE AN IMPACT ON BOTH POLITICAL
PARTIES.
>> WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS
BECAUSE THE STAKES CLEARLY, MR.
VICE PRESIDENT, ARE CRITICAL.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR J